Let's do scratch by rodeo. I wrote a love letter to my, to my partner, Shawn,
Terry, but I would like to confess that I'm also gay at the moment. Um,
Rhodes is all red and violence. All blow my life. Change what you gave me,
your glow. You it to do it.
Happy daddy way. Now I can tell you 100%. I'm definitely gay.
You're a good rapper. Oh, what else? Roses. Uh,
you go rap, bro. Ah, roses are red. Violets are blue.
Roses are red. Violets are blue roses,
all red. I um,
since you moved away, I wish I was dead and it's a,
it's another good rap song. Um, I love you so much.
Let's kiss on the lips. Absolutely hat. That's cash on their laps.
And then maybe one day I'll buy your tickets to see Chrissy hips.
I liked the way you rhymed everything. My poems don't them. I write my poems.
They're more old school like Scottish. Like I don't do the rhyming. I just.
I just go from the heart. I just talk from the heart. Let me talk to him.
To him. I've talked from the heart talking to heart. Uh,
did they have to my deal, my friend Sharjah, Patty, Patrick Mulroney,
a flat 14 friend of mine. You know, we've been in the same firehouse.
We've been doing fight fires.
We've been fighting fires together for a long time, long time.
We do a lot of overtime jobs, little part time jobs together on the side. Yeah.
Uh, I love the guy when we're playing flag football against the cops.
I like seeing him on the other line on it.
I'm decide knowing that the outside linebackers, a potty.
We're going to take down a couple of these cops. I'm like, yeah.
I like going to the Lake. See what him and not remembering it. Yeah.
I liked that. I liked that. I liked that.
I also liked that we share the same politics that also makes me feel warm.
It feels good to somebody.
I could just vent about the Democrats show buddy.
I tried it's okay. Yeah.
I can safely just call someone a democratic vegan and I ain't feel safe.
Let's just call it. Just start calling these guys avocado. Yeah.
If I just call a a guy, a yeah, a bean burrito. A avocado.
It's nice that I can be around Patty. You feel safe? Yeah.
So it's a good place to also vent about people of certain ethnicities. Yeah.
It gives me a safe place for that. Roses are red violets. All roses are red.
Violets are blue. If Trump don't win again. Yeah.
Start off with it.
You find somebody that has the same level of enthusiasm for president Trump.
And so that's why I love Patty and that's why I miss Patty and we haven't been
hanging out. That's why you might vowel in time.
It's because you just another Republican firefighter and I just love hanging out
with you and drinking beer. I just wanted to say happy Valentine's day that Tim,
I just want to go to the salty dog and drink beer. I wore it. Yeah. I liked,
I liked not remembering things with you.